these ladies are my friends now and
Hathaway is opening up about competition
among women in Hollywood and learning to
embrace the spotlight and graces the May
issue of modern luxury looking ethereal
in Giorgio Armani and Chanel ensembles
styled by La Roche the actress admits
she's learning how to deal with her
celebrity status in this social media
era telling the magazine she's opening
up to people and they can take what
resonates with them and ignore the rest
and also gets candid about the sense of
collective energy happening between her
peers in Hollywood quote where I feel I
might have in the past been sort of
brainwashed to see women as competition
I now see sisterhood this is amazing and
when it comes to the times up movement
she feels there has been seismic change
but believes everyone needs to get on
board when she's not advocating for
women and parenting her son Jonathon
with hubby Adam Schulman sans alcohol
she kicked drinking to the curb after a
five-day hangover she tells the
publication I think I never had to do a
meeting hungover when she's not on mommy
duty she's acting of course her latest
flick the hustle with rebel Wilson comes
out May 10 and she says it was hard not
to break character working alongside
rebel quote I had a stifled belly laugh
every single day I had no idea how
small-time I was until I met you candy
why are women better suited to calm than
men because we used to fake it it was
crazy
[Music]